hello and welcome to footnotes I'm here
to recap the most ravishing ideas from
around Wired first step today
the only symbol more sinister and
confusing than princes wired Enterprise
explored the theory that the UPC is in
fact the mark of the beast which would
mean the beast shops at grocery stores
instead of farmers markets perhaps
because he sunburns easily among the
many problems with this theory is the
fact that the mark should only show up
on people to designate them as followers
of the Beast if the mark is a UPC then
only the guy from the Hitman video games
and Captain Crunch are followers which
would be nice if you wanted to cut up
the rubes under enemy's mounts so what
is this beast the Bible describes it as
a sort of leopard slash lion having
seven heads and a bear's feet shown here
with a mysterious opposable thumb for
handing sticks to dragons the number
associated with the beast is of course
six six six
we now more closely associate 666 with
the devil or the Antichrist who was
probably born on June 6 2006 and is
likely currently in kindergarten
tormenting his teacher who may or may
not be Arnold Schwarzenegger sent from
the future to stop me there's even a
word for the fear of the number 666 no
joke
it's hexaco co e hexa canto hexa phobia
and the fear of pronouncing that word is
hexaco co e hexa canto hexa phobia
phobia and the fear of pronouncing the
fear of pronouncing Texaco Co in haste a
context of phobia phobia is Texaco Co
hexacopter hexa phobia phobia phobia and
I'll stop now
up next unicorns mythical rainbow
writing creatures feared by no one
except rhinos who would lose in a face
fight with them this came up on a wire
design story on superheroes one of which
is a half man half unicorn but for some
reason isn't called the Clooney corn it
was the ancient Greeks who first
described the unicorns and they're even
mentioned several times in the Bible
that means that they must have been on
Noah's Ark
which explains the rainbow because if
you really think that two of every
animal can somehow fit on a boat it's
not a stretch to attribute optical
phenomena to unicorns in medieval
folklore it was said that unicorns could
only be captured by female virgins this
explains why they run so freely at the
Jersey Shore
the earnest belief in unicorns continued
on into the Renaissance which saw the
birth of the cabinet of curiosities a
private collection of Wonders often
gathered during travels he supposed
unicorn horn was a popular item in these
collections educated visitors might
point out that they were in fact narwhal
horns but I personally wouldn't want to
argue with a man who hangs bears from
the damn ceiling it's theorized that
other horned animals like Bulls could
have been mistaken for unicorns by
people who only glimpsed their profile
remember that not many folks went to
college back then they could have even
been afraid of school a disorder called
scoliamo phobia and the fear of
pronouncing the word Scully on a phobia
is called skull
oh yeah it's called Scola fonio be a
phobia err pronouncing Scola fonio
pronouncing Scola phony obeah
it's called Scola phony obeah fobian
sorter called Scola phony obeah called
Scola phony Oni called Scola phony Oni
why can't I get it right